Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
June 19th,
2017 what's going on?
How are you doing now? Why? What's
up all that's great. That's,
you're doing good. You're
doing good. Oh, gets good.
I'm doing great. I'm actually recording
this on Sunday. Uh, June 18th.
I'm 49 years old.
My first fucking
day. First Father's Day. Oh Geez. Belt.
What did you do? God bless
you. You're in the clubhouse.
Fucking turn. You finally became a dead.
What did you do? I had a great day.
Bye. Have a great day. You know,
they go all out for mother's Day.
Did she has brunch after
brunch after this? After that,
I went over to a car show over on a Rodeo,
uh,
uh, drive. They'll drive right where?
Dale Boulevard. Rodeo Rodeo road.
Rodale drive. The fancy schmancy place.
Evidently they have a father's day,
a car show every father's day.
Obviously if it's going to call
the father state car show. Yes.
They've had it every year. And of
course, I never went. I was never a debt.
I never even heard about the fucking
thing. So I was not on the email list.
You know, Billy the kid list as
you guys call me back in the day,
you guys a five months ago,
you could still call me that.
So I was never on the email list
and a god damn. And I was like,
I'm going over there.
So we had over there and uh,
you know, it's like, you
know, the beautiful people.
You don't want people and me.
MMM.
Rich,
rich ass fucking yeah. Beverly Hills.
They call it the Beverly Hills, um,
car show. And I got to tell you,
man, it's fucking beautiful cars.
I was either going to go
to the Petersen Museum,
I was going to do that and I figured I
can go to the Petersen museum anytime.
This is the father's day one.
I got to go to that one and then
I'll do the Peterson later. Right.
So I fucking go over there. A
Peterson Museum, by the way.
Right down next to that place. That's
right. What biggie got shot? Um,
we'll share in fucking Fairfax. So
anyways, so I'm over there on Rodeo drive.
I'm checking it out, right? There's
all these rich people, you know,
there's all these beautiful fucking,
you know, I don't know what, you know,
walking around,
God knows how old they are.
They really getting good with the
plastic surgery meant they really,
really get fucking,
I was still with some amazing old
looking women walking around, you know,
where in forever 21 shit that
they bought it, you know,
I don't know one of those stores
up and down the block. Right.
So we're walking around, you
know, it's fucking hilarious.
Every restaurant was like closed over
there. They're like, fuck the dads.
He like five food trucks. Even
over there. They're like, Yay.
It's the daddy doesn't give a shit.
Show him a couple of fucking Babel
shown the Lincoln from entourage,
which they had over there,
which was fucking coolest shit.
One of the great cars out there,
the Lincoln continental
suicide doors and all that.
I'm not a convertible guy, but you know,
it worked for the show, the overhead shot,
iconic shot at this point.
Uh,
they had the Eleanor car from gone in
60 seconds, but I liked, I like all,
I always liked the weird
shit. Um, I saw like a 19,
what the fuck was only had
1961 62 or 63 Mercedes Benz,
limousine and I, everything that
was there, there was a Tucker there,
there was a fucking one of
those mid feeling of 55,
uh, Mercedes gullwing, you know, bunch
of Ferrari's Lamborghini's, you know,
they have those weird years in the 70s.
Those ones,
uh, Adam Carolla has a lot of
them. I don't mean weird like that.
Not good look and it's just like,
you know,
I always saw him as the racing
car and then to me it was for me,
I just felt it went right to magnum
Pi and it wasn't until I did Carolla's
podcast back in the day when I saw the
Lamborghinis and Ferraris and I was just
like one of these, he was
like, oh, this is it. This one,
this is that one from like the, like the
late 67, seven. Now their coolest shit.
He was ahead of the curve by the
way. Um, I was watching a local,
a newscast out here and um,
Adam Korea's a free plug here.
Adam Corolla was on and he was promoting,
he's got a,
he's got a documentary on the 24 hours
of Le Mans in the 1950s when Ford decided
that they were going to guess compete
and see what they could do over there.
And uh, they came out with the
Ford Gt. He's got this great,
I can getting rave reviews and he has
another documentary that he already put
out about the racing life of Paul Newman.
And if you go to his website,
I believe it's chassis.com something,
if you just put an Adam Corolla Le Mans,
it's going to come up.
And uh,
what I love is all I could find
on the website was just the DVD,
which is great for me as an old
man. I don't like that fucking, hey,
you downloaded and then it's in the
air and somehow it's on my computer.
And then I dumped some orange juice on
the keyboard and then I don't own it
anymore. I like the DVD.
I'm gonna I, I'm an old man.
I like the DVD that's like having
the gold behind your money.
So had I known about this,
I would have asked for both
of those for a father's day.
So instead I'm just
going to buy it myself.
So anyways,
I fucking go over there and they got
this Mercedes Benz like 1960160260 three
some in their early sixties.
And it's a a, it's a limousine.
It's fucking black. It's got
this, uh, I took a video. I know,
I always say I'm going to post it.
Then I always forget that
I say I'm going to do it,
but I'm going to try to remember here
had this beautiful red interior and um,
it was just, I was like that, that
right. That's what the fuck is he?
The older I get,
as much as I enjoy driving,
I don't enjoy driving in La because
the traffic is just fucking insane.
And my wife, my laugh, she,
Uber's all the time.
So I'm getting used to this jumping
in a car and somebody else is driving.
You know,
when I go out with her and um,
I get all this business done,
be it breaking people's balls
back on some texts, you know,
call it back fucking Joe to
Rosa is some shit better.
Call Saul's Joe to Rosa
for your consideration is
the fucking veterinarian on
that wonderful show.
Um, turn, email calls,
business shit, all of
that. And uh, you know,
you always read about these, these
fucking people out here, the,
these moguls like the
Ryan Seacrest's out here,
they don't fucking drive.
They have a drive around.
They sit in the back
and they get shit done.
They pull the curtain right
and they just backed there.
They got like the Janet
Jackson headset on.
They're fucking firing off
emails that buying stocks.
I don't know what they're doing
back there. I'm not a mogul.
It's like they're going to tell you
fucking tell someone how to be a mogul.
Then everybody's a mogul in the way you,
you just sort of,
you're just a regular guy. Next thing
you know, you've stopped at a red light.
You looking over, you look, is that Ryan
Seacrest driving his own fucking car?
What happened that this guy
had 17 fucking TV shows?
Um, anyways, I,
I could really get into that to be
honest with you. But who's kidding who,
I'm not a mogul. I, I'm just
fucking lazy and I don't know,
I think that there's this two
types of people as they get older.
This is a person that just,
you know, takes up cycling
in rock climbing and they take like a
fucking glass blowing class or some shit,
you know? And then there's other
people being like, you know, and I,
I fucking tired man. You know, I,
I'd like to chill if I get another 49
years or whatever, I get, you know,
I'm on the back nine.
Who's kidding who 49 times two is 98.
I want to make a hundred stay in
positive or who's can do all right,
feel like I'm on the 12th hole.
Um,
it'll fuck wants to drive in La.
It's fucking horrible. I would actually
thoroughly enjoy it and I would just,
if you had that kind of loop,
you free do an old fucking beautiful
car like that. You restore it,
you bring it back to life, and then you
just in the back, you know, you got,
you got, you know, you've got a little
humor door, some fucking cigars,
you know,
couple of your favorite little fucking
accoutrements being the booze there.
Then you just fuck or whatever.
You just drive around.
Well,
whatever your driver's name is, you
still call him James. Every fucking,
every a chauffeur was always
named that when, that'd be great.
You want to go to the movies? You
know, I drink too much already, man.
There's no way I can, I can handle
always having a designated driver.
I began fucking stupid going to the
supermarket. Um, speaking of which Billy,
no fun.
Oh Jesus.
Jesus Christ was seven
days in seven fucking days.
And last night I had a couple glasses of
wine. We went out with another couple.
What am I supposed to do? Everybody
at, Oh, I'm having an Italian meal.
I'm not supposed to have a little Barolo.
Come on, come on. What am I supposed to,
I had a couple of those, you know, and I,
I don't even fucking like mine. It just,
it's just, it's always reminding you of
the hangover. It's going to give you,
turned your teeth gray.
Um, but I actually enjoyed,
that's the one wine that I like.
I really enjoyed it last night and um,
I was actually gonna order
a whiskey, but uh, uh,
I almost said the referee, the waiter
forgot to come back and asked me.
At that point I was just like, fuck this,
I'm just going to stay with the wine.
And then tonight my family took me out
for father's day and I had one whiskey
and I, Oh man, I got fucking good one.
Right. I got a really good 28 years old.
And then I went outside to return a
phone call and I had set the glass down.
I came back and,
uh,
one of my red learners had bumped the
table and said they knocked a little bit
out and I didn't think
there was that much.
And then I looked down on those as big
puddle of it and I was like, Oh fuck,
that was 28 years old. I mean, the
back of my head, I was like, oh,
that's good because I'm
trying not to drink anyways,
but it was 28 years old
as shit poured in a glass.
I sipped it and then somebody
came by, boom, hit the table,
and then those are puddle of it.
Spent 20 years in a fucking barrel to
be spilled on the floor and then cleaned
up with a rag. Ah, that's a
travesty. I felt my liver crying,
but it was good because then I had the
perfect amount of booze and I was fine.
So I don't know. I know you
guys who were in Aa, you know,
collecting your little chippy poos there.
You knew it.
Yes.
Sober, you know, give
you a little cookie. Um,
got you down that chain.
There's no way,
even if I was like a
full on fucking alkie,
like I'm in AAA of alcoholism.
Um,
I never got called up to the big show.
I'm basically like Kevin Costner and
a bull Durham, except I'm drinking,
um,
that would annoy me going to Aa and
they give me my stupid chip like that.
So I'm like, I'm supposed to be
fucking chasing these things.
I've got too much of a contrarian in me.
That's the new word for content,
by the way.
I'm a bit of a Canarian uh,
Canarian a contrarion a bit of
a contrary. Yeah. Yeah. You're,
you're difficult. You or can't, you know,
you're fucking in the ass.
You're the kind of guy I have to fucking
jet went down. You're the fucking guy.
You're the guy that would get us killed.
We'd all be fucking sitting there if we
survive going, hey, you know what I say?
We go over their storage.
Everybody agreement. Yeah.
And then they always want to
go, whoa, Mu, this rich. Well,
why don't you fucking go over there buddy.
We had mauled by a bobcat.
We'll wait for you to slowly
die and then they're there.
There's a new nourishment for the rest
of this fucking walked down this snowy
God forsaken Tundra.
Yeah.
Anyways, sorry. Um, the
fuck am I talking again? So,
so we go to the car show, right? None
of the fucking restaurants are open.
Fuck the dads. It's like
food trucks. Nobody gives it.
You know what's funny though? I didn't
give a shit. My wife was upset. Oh my God.
Why do we know any of
these places are open?
She's like, are you alright with
us? Like, yeah, I don't give a shit.
I don't give a shit. You
know, I really don't. I am.
I am the way I'm wired like a guy.
I walked around,
I looked at some shiny cars.
I'm happy. It's hot as shit.
Let's get back in the car and go
home. I'm fine. Completely fine.
Brunch. That's, that's some you shit
turning this whole fucking thing to
do a whole day. Yeah. Father's Day.
You leave that. I had to buy the
perfect father's day. And then, um,
I didn't even say I started my day.
Who fucking,
uh, no fun Billy. I can wake
up now like super early and um,
okay.
I finally have a little drum space,
about 20 ways a little row,
a little Jesus Christ who came to talk
a little ways away from like 20 minutes
away from my house. I got
a little rehearsal studio,
right? It can just rent them.
And I got the smallest fucking one.
Like if I stretch out,
I can touch the walls on all sides.
And I got this little fucking,
that little sonar kit that I bought, the
Martini Kit, 16 inch bass, a bass drums,
which cracks me up because I was playing
that giant bottom one that at a 26 inch
fucking bass drum and a,
I'm trying to, you know,
just go in a completely diff,
different direction after all of these
goddamn years of just fucking trying to
ape everything that, uh,
that he did. And I just, I,
it just hit me one fucking day.
I told you what,
if one day I just sat there and I said,
what is this fucking guy came back to
life and he came walking into my house.
I keep saying this on the podcast,
right? And I was just like, hey man,
John Bonam, Holy Shit. Hey, I'm a big fan
of yours. Come in and look at my drum kit.
And I had his exact drum kit
right down to the Rogers high hat.
He would have looked that he would've
slowly backed out of the fucking room.
And what was funny is, now I'm going
down this whole fucking rabbit hole.
You know, I'm listening to Pan Tara
and fucking Primus in Miles Davis.
Figure that one out.
Listening to all of fucking
great drummers from Philly, Joe,
Tony Williams to fucking Jack Dejan it
just listen to these fucking geniuses
and I'm trying to get something
else in my fucking head.
And uh,
through reading up on Tony Williams,
I went down this fucking
rabbit hole full of,
I don't know how many hours on
the Internet, just trying to,
Ellie's tracks I was listening
to and trying to see if I could,
there's so many tracks with Tony is
just killing it live and they just won't
show him.
It's so fucking annoying though.
We showing miles or cold train a fucking
nickel. [inaudible] plaintiff Coltrane,
Myles are fucking,
was it shorter that he played with?
I don't know if they're always
showing those guys. Yes.
It's like if everybody else stops playing,
they'll finally fucking show him.
It's annoying. Um, but you know,
typical, they never show the drum.
That's why I love the
Romantics when I was a kid.
And what I like about you came out and
I finally got the w the drummer was
singing.
If the drummer sang then there would
be on hotel California with Don Henley.
You'd see the drummer the whole
fucking time. Okay. Other than that,
you would shit out of luck.
Um, so anyways, I ended up,
when you read about Tony,
that leads to Billy Cobham,
which leads to fucking eventually,
you know, I dunno Vinnie,
Kali Yoga and Steve Smith
and all these fucking guys.
And then they start talking about the
guys they listen to and then you go back
around again.
It's amazing.
So I ended up finding this
quote that really made me
feel good about getting rid of the drum
kit that I did because sometimes I think
going on, man, I always wanted that
kid. And I finally fucking had it,
and then I just always think,
yeah,
and you sat down and played it and
you sounded like you so and it was too
fucking big for you and you
have all these other ideas.
Why don't you go pursue those?
And I just stumbled on this
quote by Vinny Kali Uta, right?
That's actually transcends playing drums.
You can apply this to anything. It's,
he says, this is what he was trying
to find his own style. He said,
I went through periods where I
tried to imitate Tony and Billy.
That's Tony Williams and Billy Cobham.
He goes by eventually
realized how dangerous it was.
Basically trying to imitate those
guys. That goes, I began to ask myself,
what am I saying?
I wasn't saying anything.
It had been said before and
had a reason for being said,
but I didn't have a reason.
I wasn't making a statement.
I was just repeating it like a parrot.
By imitating and copying someone else,
a person becomes a parrot.
I saw the trap and I knew as great as
those guys were and still are that I had
to find my own voice and I was
like, God dammit, look at that.
That applies to stand up comedy.
That applies to fucking washing cars.
Do you want to be one of the greats?
You know how many times can you watch
misdemeanor Augie do the wax on,
wax off before you're going
to fucking break out of that.
Come up with a new way
to do it. Right. I know.
What the fuck to tell
you. I'm just happy. So now I got
this place so I wake up now cause um,
you know
the way my daughter sleeps,
she sleeps in these four hour chunks.
So she finally falls asleep,
you know,
around two in the morning after she
slept from my, you know, eight to 12.
Then she'd be like up for like
an hour and a half of some shit.
And then she sleeps till like seven.
My wife feeds her and then she
goes back to sleep again until 10.
So that window right there from seven to
10. Now, I just been jumping in the car,
drive 20 minutes down the street.
Nobody's up.
There's no musicians over at that place.
You know, they're just getting done,
doing blow. They're going home. You know,
I'm there at like eight in the fucking
morning and I get to play for like a nice
solid hour having the
time of my fucking life.
I don't know why I didn't do
this for myself years ago.
I didn't never dawned on me to do it.
I was always trying to play him in the
fucking house and trying to find quiet
ways to do it.
Cause who's kidding?
Who drums are fucking annoying other
unless you're the person playing him. Um,
so I finally got this place and I'm
a, I'm beyond psych, so we'll see.
We'll see what this little
kit leaves me. Um, but, uh,
I don't know, whatever. I'm just
saying it was a great father's Day.
So I went out tonight and then, uh,
get a nice framed picture of me,
uh,
hold my beautiful daughter and I could
not be having my arms around her anymore.
And she looks content is hell.
It's was an instant classic.
I'm kissing her on the
cheek and I get it framed.
I'm looking at right now sitting on my
desk and fucking psyched. So I'm happy.
Father's Day, Father's Day to
all the fathers out there. Uh,
you know, and if he used to play
drums, you want to play him again.
Go get one of those, get that fucking,
that quest love little break beats set.
Go find some fucking studio
space cause she like one 25,
200 bucks a month. Who
gives a fuck? You know,
go get it and go down there and
bring you fucking, you know,
or find a studio space like,
you know where I used to play,
I never used to say that cause I didn't
want anybody bugged me down there. Um,
the best place that I
found out here in La,
if you don't have time to get
a drum kit and all that shit,
but if you just want to go play someplace
is cascade studios down on Santa
Monica Av just east of Highland.
It's the shit. It's fucking cleaned.
The drum kits are great. And, uh,
it was the first class place and I,
I went to a bunch of places that
was the best place that I've found.
So free plug there, it, speaking of
that speaking and Oh, by the way,
everybody keeps telling me to watch the
fucking Lakers Celtics documentary thing
that they got on ESPN. So I
have to check that out. Um,
but before I do that, before I do
that have fucking fucked up too.
God Damn podcast, that
podcast, they fucked up the
password
ain't no complex. These things have to
be now, you know, I, you know, you know,
I hate you fucking put a nice easy one
in and then they just say to you like,
Oh yeah, that's not a, that's not good
enough. That's not fucking good enough.
It's like, well, why
don't I determine that?
Why are you acting like I'm in
the Pentagon? I don't give a fuck.
You know what I mean? Um, oh,
you know what's hilarious too.
And now that I've got a, I'm
out of my bottom phase, um,
I still played to some Zeplin today.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
When I was over there.
But um,
somebody showed me his fucking, remember
that car in the song remains the same.
That crazy looking.
I don't know who made it,
Ford or some shit that he had that held
that crazy paintings and stuff like that.
You know,
you always wonder what happened to that
shit is somebody bought it and then
somebody else bought it
and now it's up for sale.
It's like 250 fucking grant.
You always going to buy that
thing. I'm, I'm Jim or say, uh,
the colts.
I think that guy's going to end up having
like the equivalent of
Jay Leno's car collection.
He's going to have that
with musical artifacts.
I mean the guy's getting to the point
where he can kind of fuck with the rock
and roll hall of fame.
He's got like a Prince Guitar.
He's got Jerry Garcia's guitar.
If you had John Bonam car,
I mean,
that really adds to the collection.
Then you put your fucking,
yeah.
Printers, guitars and all this.
Charlie Parker's saxophone,
whatever the fuck else that
guy owns in the back. Yeah.
Some hookers come over. He starts
doing blow, whatever the fuck it is.
He does mean it could, could be a
good time. No. Um, anyways, let's uh,
let's read some advertising
here upside down. Boy,
you turn me alright. Upside. There's a
better way round a round. You turn to me.
Remember that one?
That's a,
that's a obscure [inaudible]
is take the upset down.
You turn me [inaudible] um,
upside.
There's a better way for you to buy
business travel. It's called upside.com.
Every time you buy a trip at upside,
you'll save your company a ton of money
and they give you an Amazon gift card
worth hundreds of dollars.
Upsides able to do this because they
bundle your flights and hotel together for
one low price. Bundled saving.
Bundled prices saves money.
But what the fuck? How do I still get
a gift card worth hundreds of dollars?
I mean, if you get a bundle
and it's going to save money,
I'm not going to come out around $300.
Then you get to give me 200 back.
This is like the greatest
fucking deal ever.
If you're a frequent business traveler,
you're company's saves a ton of money and
you could get thousands a year in gift
cards just for buying your
air and hotel together. Upset.
Plus you still get all your
miles. If you're shopping
for business travel, travel,
you'd be crazy not to checkout
upside.com oh I get this.
This is if you buying like
business tickets, is that
what it is? Business class.
It takes just three minutes to see how
much you can say by buying your flights
and hotel together for one low price and
right now when you use my name Barbie,
you are,
are you guaranteed to get at least $100
Amazon at least a $100 Amazon gift card
for your first trip? It probably
depends on how much the ticket is.
I would guess that's my name.
Barbie you are to get at least a
$100 Amazon Gift Card for free.
Save big on travel and get
a big gift card every trip.
I love upside.com ever dental
even though I've never used it.
upside.com minimum purchase required.
See Site for complete details.
I should start fucking using that.
Yeah.
Did identity,
you know,
you give me an Amazon card and
then I got to go out and buy shit.
I'm trying to get shit out of my
fucking house. Well, I know I didn't.
I re gift it. I'll give it to somebody
else. See you go, you buy shit.
You drown in your own fucking
okay.
Artifacts. Whatever the hell you
did. You find a black Tux, everybody.
Black Tux. There's only so many
opportunities in life to wear a Tuxedo.
So when your big day or special event,
what are the days,
you know,
getting married.
Going to a prom.
Okay.
Uh, you somehow know the mayor and
he's fucking got something going on.
Do you know what else did you
wear when you're on trial?
That'd be fucking hilarious.
Where it Tuxedo?
It's like you're shown respect and
saying you're a little crazy. Suny.
If they convict, you can be like, Hey,
give me the guy's out of his fucking mind.
Who is the Tuxedo? Who,
where does it talk soon?
MMM,
there's so many copies. Okay. When you,
when your big day or special event comes
a rolls around this spring or summer
look,
just as great as you feel with suits from
black tux.com with high quality rental
suits and Tuxedos
delivered to your doorstep.
The Black Tux gives you a new way to
rent plus with their free home. Try on,
you can see the fit and feel the quality
of your suit months before your event
and the best part is it's
completely done online.
The Blue tux.com lets you create your
look and choose from tons of styles.
Stylist selected outfits,
suits like these,
usually retail retail for $1,200 but at
the black Tux they start at just $95 if
you have any questions or issues,
man, what's your issue man?
Their expert customer care team has
your back every step of the way.
After ordering your suit will
arrive 14 days before your event.
Why do I blow off Commas?
After ordering your suit will arrive
14 days before your event period.
If anything else,
if anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will s the black Tux will
send you a free replacement right away.
When your event's over,
just drop your rental back in the mail.
Okay.
We use wadded up in the fucking box.
Shipping is free both ways.
How easy is that standout in your bed?
Just thinking of all the
stains on the Tuxedo.
I'd have a fucking a hazmat suit on,
dude.
If you have a Tuxedo at some point
in the night yet Dick's coming out,
that's just a fact. Stand out at your
event for the right reason with the black,
the Black Tux to get $20 off
your purchase, visit the black
tux.com/burr. That's the black
talks.com/burr for $20 off your purchase.
Two more reads guys, hang in
there. Hang the fuck in there. Um,
is bored with my reading
as you are legal zone
in order to successfully run your business
attention to detail is so critical.
One contract slip up.
Ah,
Jesus or illegal misunderstanding I
didn't do it can really set you back.
Fortunately, there's
legal zoom, zoom. Yeah.
You may already know that over a million
Americans have used legal zoom to start
their business, but legal zoom services
go well beyond business formation.
They built a nationwide
network of independent
attorneys who can provide legal
answers to day to day questions
you have about your business.
Because let's face it, things
like trademarks, employment laws,
and lease agreements can
get pretty complicated.
That's such a nice way of saying you're
too scatterbrained to want to deal with
this shit.
Let us handle it.
So don't waste your valuable time trying
to wrap your head around all the fine
print.
Use Legal Zoom for that so they could
focus so you could focus on growing your
business.
Instead,
you'll get the legal help you need
without being billed by the hour.
Since legalzoom is in a law firm,
I've never understood that sentence.
Get legal advice from fucking
place that isn't a law firm.
Go to legalzoom.com today and be sure to
enter to enter code bar in the referral
box for special savings
only@legalzoom.com.
Lastly,
but not leastly Jolly Shave Club do
dollar shave club is the smarter choice.
You'll get your great
shave at a great price,
conveniently delivered right to your deal.
You no longer have to Schlep to this
studio a to buy a cheap disposable razor
that gives you a cheap shave or spend a
fortune on razors with gimmicky shaving
technology you don't fucking need.
All right.
When you use your dollar Shave
Club's executive razor with it,
do I have to cabbies out?
Um,
the blade gently glides across your balls
giving you a smooth Shane up your face.
Dr Carver's shave butter is
transparent for the more prices.
Precise shave helps present
ingrown hairs and fights.
Razor bumps.
There you go.
They handle all the way to white
to black people there. Huh? Uh,
make the smarter choice by joining
Dollar Shave Club for a limited time.
New members can get their first month
of the executive razor with a tube of
their Dr Carver's. Easy, shea butter
for $5 with free shipping. After that
raises it just a few bucks a month.
That's a $15 value for only five bucks.
There are no hidden fees and no
commitments. Cancel anytime you like.
You can only get this offer
exclusively@dollarshaveclub.com
slash [inaudible]
that's dollar shave club.com/birth
thank fucking Christ. That's all over
over.
MMM. All right. So anyways,
I really fucking overextended myself.
Uh,
this month I said Yes
to way too much shit.
And for July my answer is going to be no.
I don't give a fuck what anybody
asked me. No a believe. No,
I'm not doing it. I'm not
fucking doing it. I uh, I got,
I'm on the road again. [inaudible]
chicka boom, boom, boom.
I'm doing the roast of David
Ortiz, uh, this week, Thursday.
And um, you know, I've got to figure
out how to, I don't do that a,
I'm not saying this guy, Waka Waka, but
this Booper bull bull, Yada Yada Yada.
You know, those fucking roast jokes
for some reason, the, the format of,
of roast jokes is still from like the
1950s. I don't understand why that is.
I have to figure out how to do this shit.
Um,
so and so is here. You know, last time
I saw I had liked that it had a fuck.
You know,
they still use that except the young
guys now they all say aids and cunt and
fucking, it just, it's just so
over the top, you know, nine 11.
It's always like,
I gotta figure out how the fuck to do
this and I only have four days to do it.
And of course I'm busy as shit.
So, uh, I dunno what to do here.
So, but this is the last
thing. If I just get past this,
which I will either by doing a good job,
a mediocre job,
or eating my fucking balls on it. The
bottom line is it's over. You know,
it's a 12 minute spot.
I just have to get,
if I get past this fucking roast,
the rest of them I've gone up the
rest of my year. It's downhill,
Billy. No Fund is saying no to everything.
What do you want? When is it not?
I can't make it now.
Can't do it.
[inaudible] know what it'd be like
that fucking buzzard. Way Back.
[inaudible] bashful
buzzard on a bugs bunny.
No, the whole market it
though. That's going to be me.
I have to start fucking
doing that because uh,
yeah, it's not good. It's just
too much shit. And I am a, I'm a,
and now with the kid, I'm
fucking, I'm exhausted.
It's nine 22 at night and I was
ready for bed two fucking hours ago.
It's just my cutie pie
doesn't asleep til about nine.
Um,
and you know what's great about no booze.
You sleep like a fucking baby. I
mean, booze, we'll put you to sleep,
but the next morning you wake up
and you're just like, you know,
yeah,
you wake up, you feel like you
should be tied to a chair, you know,
and there's some guy just waiting
for you to come around to continue
interrogating you by punching you in
the head. And then you realize like, no,
I punched myself in the head with
all those fucking drinks. Um,
so I'm actually really enjoying it
despite the fact that drank the last two
nights. I have one tonight and half
of it's built on the fucking ground.
All right. Fucking judge me. All right.
I decide I'm in my own Aa. Okay.
I still learned a chip today.
I just feel like for me,
having my own a is a good thing.
Speaking of from me in reality show stars,
you're not going to fucking believe
who I think was at that car show today.
We're walking around with
looking at data that's fucking,
this two door Cadillac that
I swear to God was like,
it was like two town cars put
together. Um, incredible fucking car.
Yeah.
Gigantic. Oh my God. I saw
this one Jaguar, you know
the one that has the early,
that one of the head in the
60s with the long fucking hood.
I'm not the one from the 50s that Sinatra
had that won the James Bond era one.
You know the one and like the patch
back open like a fucking regular door.
This guy showing it off,
right.
He's got the back door open and then
the hood opens like the reverse way,
you know, from the windshield out looks
cool as shit. And then I look in there,
he's got like some small blocks,
small block Chevy engine in there,
you know, I don't know. That's
what you want to fucking do.
I don't know why you would
do that. Um, anyways, I um,
yeah,
so walking around and looking at those
cars and all of a sudden he is this,
these people on like,
you know,
the given out awards to cars and
shit and that there's these listings.
This person on the microphone going,
I think that's Caitlyn Jenner.
Yeah,
I think Caitlyn Jenner's. Yeah. And I was
like, no fucking way. I got to go seek,
I gotta go see K. Right. I've got to
go see when by the time we got there,
I'm not even sure if it was,
but like Nia said that Bruce,
it gets confusing. He sees, she
said she's really into cars.
So I got confused saying like,
all right was, was he not into it?
And then can that happen?
Do hobbies change?
Then I knew what she was saying.
It's like, no, he was into him.
He's always been into him
and now he's become Kaitlin.
Tr uh,
I want to sit transferred.
What's the fucking word you're
supposed to say? Transitioned
helicopter. November one,
five, three Sierra hotel on
with you. Information. Bravo.
Requesting,
talking transition through a transition
to, uh, you know, being Kaitlyn.
But the hobby stay the same.
Yeah.
There you go.
Who would've know that?
I would think you'd take up
some other hobbies, right?
Maybe you wouldn't.
I gotta look this up.
This is fucking weird.
Cause I know you take hormones and stuff,
right?
So does that make it into other shit?
It's, it's fine. It's fascinating.
You know,
and you know what's funny is they're going
to keep doing the same way they doing
the plastic surgery.
Whether,
you know it's going to keep looking
better and better and better.
You know what I mean? Same Way, you know,
everything keeps getting
better and better and better,
except for the fucking environment,
you know? Um, oh, by the way,
I did a fucking benefit the other
night and flea was in the crowd.
I can't fucking believe I didn't give
him a shout out for given a shit about
bees.
Okay.
There was one of the few positive things
I saw about the environment last year
was that flee somehow. Got It. You know,
fleas up the fucking bees, a dying off
and fleet shows up like a goddamn hero
and that he gets into these beekeeping
stuff. He's got the whole
suit and everything. I saw
this whole article on it.
Eddie, he's, he's
hooking up like a little,
like there was like 10,000 of them
hanging out in his backyard. You know?
You know what's funny is that's one of
those things your neighbors would be
annoyed at because they don't
understand photosynthesis.
I don't know where that fucking word
came from, but I, I literally, I think I,
I think I used it correctly,
isn't that when the bees go from flower
to flower and stuff gets on their cute
little feet, you know, a cute little
beef feet, you know what I mean?
And then they pollinate
shit inadvertently.
Yeah.
They're out there running errands for
the Queen, right? The Queen Bee. Um,
the fuck was I talking about?
Oh, I gotta look this shit up.
When you transition,
do your hobbies change fucking list.
Am I going to get put on, look
in this shit up. Oh, come on man.
Don't do this to me. Come on
Internet. Come on Internet. Huh?
Can you fucking work for once in
your life? You fucking content.
Okay.
Can you believe someone who can't even
get Internet in his whole house is
talking about having a chauffeur?
I mean,
how fucking first world country is that
habit change is easy when people move in
your house for strategies
to change your habits.
Was that not specific enough?
Okay.
I, this has to be, I have to be wrong.
Yeah.
You transition to woman,
do your hobbies change.
Okay.
13 ways to master the transition
from college to the real world.
Habit changes easier.
How to successfully transition your diet,
nerd fitness, health, and your forties
wow. You know what? I searched to twice,
I guess so Bruce was intuit.
Now Bruce is
Katelyn Katelyn's like, you
know, good on you Bruce.
Way to get those fucking cars
cause I'm still digging them.
That's fucking amazing. You know, I
hope someone I know fucking transitions.
I just want to see that whole God damn
thing. You know something's got it.
Something, it's, it's gotta be something,
right?
Does your preference,
a color change?
If you taken hormones like you're
fucking would like the chemicals, right?
Is it at fucking amazing how I just
refuse to read about shit and I just
continue to ask questions
while answering them,
but this is how I come to conclusions
and then I can somehow legally get on
stage with the microphone
and do a fucking podcast.
I can't imagine how many people who used
to be men and are now women are just
slapping their female forehead.
They're transitioned forehead right now.
Listening to me as I'm talking to him.
I apologize to anybody out there
transitioning. I don't fuck them.
Why would I think that? Yeah. Cause
she said she's really into cars.
It doesn't take a not to trip me up.
That's all I'm saying. All right.
Let's read some shit here, right.
Mute math and Cole bear. Hey Billy.
Boom Bap. Boom Bap. Um,
thanks for putting me onto mute math.
Uh Oh my God.
That fucking amazing fucking incredible
band. They've got a brand new album out.
Whatever you kids say they got some brand
new shit that you can download through
the fucking air, man.
Capture it on your device.
Share it with your friends, man. Um,
this guy says,
I've seen the name before
but never listened and they
are all caps. Fucking dope.
Uh, just bought a ticket to see them
on their tour in September. Dude,
you are not going to be disappointed.
They're fucking is good as their
bank or their, their albums are,
they're fucking incredible life.
Fucking incredible. Ben. Um,
and then he said to me,
he told me to check out these bands.
It says checkout big data in Portugal.
I don't understand this next sentence.
It says the man Comma,
I think you might dig them. Is the
man also a band? I'll look it up.
All right. If my Internet hasn't shut down
after that last stupid fucking search,
keep drumming and make Steven keep
drumming and making Steven Colbert or
uncomfortable. Oh, I did this Steve
Colbert show last Thursday aired Friday.
I wasn't making them
uncomfortable. He, he enjoyed it.
I had a great time with them. He's a, uh,
I met him briefly one time at some
benefit, but uh, he's a really good dude.
It was fucking amazing to go back and do
that show cause that's where Letterman
used to tape and it's still
fucking ice cold in there.
It's still roughly like the same setup.
And it's just weird because coal
bears desk is over with a band is,
and um, I talked to him, you
know, during the break on and go,
oh, this is crazy being
over here. You know,
I did stand up on Letterman like four
or five times and this is where I always
look over. And Felicia and
Paul Shaffer, Anton fig,
all the whole band was over there and now
the desk is here. And he said that, um,
he asked Letterman where you should put
the desk and Letterman set on the right
side saying that he always wanted to sit
over there, but Johnny sat over there.
So out of respect, he sat on
the other side. That's how much,
you know, the level of respect that
wasn't made. Just amazing story.
The lead of a lover's SPEC that Letterman
had for Carson. And why wouldn't you?
The guys, the king of it all. Uh, but
Letterman was the car of my generation.
Alright. Phelps versus
the shock. Uh, Bill,
I just listened to your,
uh,
Monday morning or your Thursday afternoon
just before Monday podcast and enjoyed
your rant about the upcoming fight between
Mcgregor and Mayweather. I, it's not,
it wasn't a rant.
Was it a rant?
I just was discussing the fucking subject.
If I was screaming and yelling,
ranting and raving, that is
a fucking rent. You know,
I'm going to look up ransom.
I'm probably really wrong.
It's wrong. A mom, you know,
if you transition your
fucking habits change,
why the fuck would I be wrong
about this rant definition?
Come on. Oh, somehow I go to rant
now. What the fuck is that now? Rant.
You can't come on
definition.
Okay.
Rant definition.
Speak or shout at length in a wild,
impassioned way.
Yeah. She was still ranting
on the, I don't know. Wow.
I think this just goes back to me being
from Massachusetts in my ideas of,
of yelling and fucking
being out of control.
I just different than everybody else's.
But you'd want to say a ranted finally,
fine. Whatever. Um,
yeah. I just don't want,
I fucking hate most about that
McGregor Mayweather fight.
Aside from the fact that that Mcgregor
is only going to be allowed to box
B,
that guy's a fucking Swiss army knife of
death and that they only let them take
out the spoon. You know? Um,
you want to fucking annoys the shit
out of me about that fight as I know.
I'm going to order it. I know I'm going
to order it. How do you lay off that?
Once they found out it's only
going to be a hundred bucks.
I thought it would be like 200 bucks.
I thought they will both make
it 100 million, I guess May.
Whether it makes a hundred million
Mcgregor makes 20 million for whatever
fucking reason.
How up is that?
I think the guy that isn't,
you know,
if they were doing the fact that Mcgregor
isn't allowed to do what the fuck you
know,
we could do,
which is put Mayweather right on his
back and the thing would be over in 30
fucking seconds,
he should be getting 100 million.
Yeah,
this is a walk in the park for Mayweather.
This is his fucking strike.
And if we went the other way,
Mcgregor was allowed to use all
of his fucking fighting skills,
then may whether she get the hundred
million. This is classic, may one it,
this guy's a fucking genius.
He's getting an entirely his way and
he's making $80 million more than this
other fucking guy. Um, anyways, he goes,
did you see that Michael Phelps is going
to race a great white shark for some
discovery channel thing? I fucking
refused. That's a joke, right?
That has to be a joke.
Do I have to look this up?
I thought you might like that one. That's
that. That is fucking ridiculous. I'm um,
all right. I got to look it up, dude. Even
if the shark was full, I mean, that's,
this is like the Mayweather fucking
McGregor fight. This is what he does
mean Phelps Swims, but he also does
other shit. He goes to restaurants.
You know what I mean?
He hits a bong every once in awhile.
What the fuck does a shark do? It's
all it does. There's no fucking way.
There's no self. Oh my God. It can't know.
Phelps Verse Shark.
This can't be fucking real
Michael Phelps to race a great,
uh, to race against a great white shark
in shark week's Phelps Verse Shark.
Jesus Christ. Whenever I haven't just
been on the fucking Wheaties box,
not making enough money doing that.
Michael Phelps isn't done swimming yet.
The 23 time I'll be 23
time Olympic gold medals.
This guy is 23 gold fought.
You know what?
This guy wants to race us. You
know, we, of course he does.
He's done with human beings.
I think a shark is,
is a good tune up fight when you're going
into the ocean. I think this is who,
I don't know who put this together.
Maybe it was Mayweather he sent me.
He always picks the
perfect fucking opponent.
You go in there and gets a great white
shark. You know what I mean? They're,
they're not known for their speed,
are they?
It's always dolphin zipping around.
It's always the shit that they have
to fucking catch. That's fast, right?
Than the slowest thing gets caught.
All right,
23 time Olympic gold medalist will
compete in the most adrenaline filled race
yet when he swims against a great
white shark for this discovery channel.
Shark Week. All right, so
how do I handicap this?
Are they starting in the water?
Is the shark got to get up on that fucking
block two and wait for the whistle?
Are we've got a false start?
We got a false start.
We have a difficulty explaining to
the shark what the fucking whistle is.
He's just so freaked out that he's out
of his natural atmosphere here. Um,
and Phelps verse shark,
Great Gold Verse.
Great white is what they're calling this.
The retired athlete will take on
the oceans most efficient Predator
in a competition of speed.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ. Can you imagine, Oh,
who is Nike putting up the swim
goggles for the fucking shark.
MMM.
Okay.
All right.
And I guess Phelps tweeted something.
I was able to do something
that I'd always wanted to do.
Be in a cage and dive
with great white sharks.
MMM.
Wait, is he married? He's got a kid.
No. Good Fam. First Birthday party. Hey,
happy father's day to him.
What kind of a dad he's got?
You know what? He's got all that gold, you
know, you know what's funny? The dollar,
the entire US economy could
collapse and he's going to be fine.
He's got 23 gold medals.
You just melt those fucking thing down.
You make a little nickel size coins.
That guy's eating subs for the
rest of his fucking life. Um,
Phelps great white race isn't
the only shark week special.
He'll be appearing in the
father of one will also join.
I don't give a fuck about what he's doing
together.
The trio will dispel myths
and misconceptions and teach
Phelps the proper way to
get up close and personal with
hammerheads and great whites.
Okay.
You know what's funny about fucking the
discovery channel after all these years
of being the champions,
the absolute champions of
miss information about sharks,
that you'd always watched
their things on the sharks.
MMM.
You'd always watch these
things on the sharks
and uh,
while you watch the program, they'd
always say all this, you know,
these things are being hunted down, there
aren't misunderstood, blah, blah, blah.
But when you watch the
fucking advertising,
yeah.
For that week, Shark
week, it was always the,
there was like another jaws movie
was coming out was really bad.
So now I guess they're finally feeling
guilty or maybe some younger people came
in on the discovery channel
and they're finally done a,
I dunno, shitting on sharks. So wait,
where are they going to be
in a fucking saltwater pool
if they're in a pool?
I like Phelps for the simple fact that
I have a feeling that the shark's going
to go out of its lane and be disqualified.
And at the very least,
the shark can't do that little somersault
flip at the end of the fucking pool.
Um, Jesus Christ is this,
this is what the world is.
The world of sport is becoming.
Um, I dunno, back in the day,
used to have those fucking fat bald
guy, strongman, Theo always bald, right?
Some about lifting weights back in
the day, you know, you went bald.
They would always be pulling
trains with their teeth and shit.
Yeah.
All right. First Time listening. Hey Bill,
first time listening to your podcast,
my husband and I came to La for the Rose
Bowl last year and saw your standup.
We it. Thank you. Thanks
for taking so much.
Thanks so much for take talking
in detail about jazz and sports.
I think this show,
this think this shows a lot of respect
for your audience. We like cool shit.
Obviously we like to stand up.
Don't be afraid to go into technical
details about whatever. It's interesting.
Any who happy podcasting. Wow. All right.
There's two people that are enjoying it.
Um,
I think I talked about it a little bit.
I downloaded all of this fucking
miles Davis Shit. I am like a,
I was a huge miles Davis fan
like in the early nineties,
and my favorite album was in a silent way.
And I read his autobiography,
I got like fucking,
I mean I had all his shit on like cassette
tapes. I even got like on the corner,
which he talks about in his book how and
Herbie Hancock came out with chameleon.
Like that's what he was trying to do,
that head hunters album.
But you know,
he's blamed the record labels saying that
they know they fucked up the promotion
of it. Um, but I got into
all of that shit and then
I moved to New York and I stopped
playing drums because uh, you know,
I was living in a walkthrough fucking
bedroom apartment and I just drums it too
goddamn loud. I didn't play
for like five, six years.
And then I started back up again. So I
started in [inaudible] 88 and I've been,
I would like a five year break in there.
So I've been playing about 19 years.
Is that it? Whether it is, I don't know
what the fuck it is, but um, anyways,
Dave Brubeck Jess stuff here. We
got more drunk shit. Ah, dear.
Billy backbeat not the exact
error you were asking for,
but Dave Brubeck's band experimented with
some crazy time signatures starting in
the early sixties. Look for the album,
the Dave Brubeck quartet at Carnegie Hall.
I bought it when I was a music major
in college and it was a borderline
spiritual experience.
It's got songs in 11,
four aptly named 11 four.
Wait a minute, 11 for now. How the
fuck does that work out? 11 four.
So you just count. That's when you
would, you've count that just up to 11.
All right. So that's just basically it's
like playing three, three bars of four,
and then you just play one bar three,
four and you just lop off that last beat,
right? Five, four, take five, nine,
eight blue Rondo, Alla Turk. Uh,
not only are the song's great,
but the audio quality is
impressive for the time period.
Every once in awhile you can even hear
Dave or another member of the band blurt
out a cool jazzy during a solo.
It really immerses you in the time period
and culture. All right. You know what,
this is a classic.
I'm going to download this and listen to
this with from really nice headphones.
MMM. He probably wished that I,
you know, did some drugs. Um,
if you listened to a checkout,
the track Castilian drums
at the four minute mark,
there's a drum solo where he turns to
snare off and does some really cool and
creative stuff with his hands
and his sticks on the stairs.
If you look at Joe Morello Shit where
he's playing with his hands and stuff.
And then once John Bonam playing
with his fucking hands, um,
I'm sure he Morella wasn't the first two.
You only got to do it.
But there's just a couple things where
he's hitting with the back of his hand
and shit and you see bond and do that.
But then there's also like,
like youtube and all
that shit did not exist.
Would Barnum was coming up so
he was over in England.
The odds of him checking that out and
actually seeing it is it's so fucking,
I don't know how people we're able to,
you definitely listened
to everything you could,
but to actually get to watch all the
venues fucking in when some something came
on the TV, you just fucking sat there and
watched it. There was no hitting pause.
There's no, all this is going to
be a rerun and if you missed it,
you fucking missed it. Um, anyways,
this guy says thanks and go fuck yourself
with that shiny new high head stand.
Jesus Christ. All right. Join in the army.
Yeah.
Hey Nia, if you want to come
in as a question for you.
Yeah, grab a, grab a mic,
bring in the Tyco and grab a
Mike Breaking in the TYC and grab
a Mike [inaudible], la La, la,
la La. Get your ass in
here. Do the pod cast.
Buh.
Where are you?
Oh, you're coming. It's hot as
hell in here. And open a window.
Why don't we open a window? I don't
know. I waiting for the okay. Can you,
uh, can you, there's a microphone over
there. Can you in the closet area?
Oh, Jesus. She's a, she's a cutie. Yeah.
Well I can't do a podcast and all the
kid at the same time. Jesus Christ.
Where my multitasking.
Hey Body.
What am I looking for?
A Mike up on,
on top of the fucking thing there on
top of that, that thing straight ahead.
She's got it. Please don't tip over
my computer. Don't tip it over. Um,
all right. This is perilous here. I'm
holding her and as a computer here,
she's gonna knock it over and she's
gonna knock it over. What's up,
Cutie Pie? What's up cutie?
All right, plug it in there.
Plug it in, plug it in. And here
we go. Ladies and gentlemen,
coming back to the podcast,
I don't need to put the screen.
You don't need to put a windscreen
on any of the window open.
Can you grab your beautiful
daughter in here? Please,
please me.
Crazy.
I know, I know, I know, I know. All
right. Here's a question for you.
How did you pull the map up?
Alright, here's your question.
All right, you're ready? Dancing wedding.
Okay. Hey there, Billy back. Freckled uh,
my girlfriend and myself are attending
a wedding for our good friends too.
Gay Fellas, this is a very progressive
podcast by the way that you're doing.
Yes.
Oh well cause I already brought up Caitlyn
Jenner and I learned something today
when you kind of freaked me out when you
said like, oh, she's really into cars.
Why did that freak you out then?
For,
cause I know I had to do the math in my
head. I was like, was Bruce not into cars?
So then I was like, no, wait.
I remember reading sports illustrated
had Porsches and he was a pilot and all
that shit. Right. Does his pilot's
license? It must transfer over.
Do you gotta change the name of how fun?
How crazy is that?
And then you've got to go down there
and be like, listen, I'm this guy now.
I'm sure it's, it's every, everyone
knows their Caitlyn Jenner is alright,
so if you're not famous, but if you're
not famous, yeah. If you're not famous,
you probably got to do who got some
pain in to do. But I am, I'm gonna,
you know, I'm going to get you
for mother's Day next year.
They speaking into a mic class.
Sorry.
All right, so here it is. Um, by the way.
So I googled it when you
transition to your habits change
and nothing came up.
So I guess it does.
Okay.
What's the color you wouldn't take one
little thing would be kind of like,
Oh shit, now I'm into this. Have
you taken like hormones and stuff?
Like when something change, your favorite
color would change? I don't think so.
It doesn't affect your brain,
right?
Why don't you allow to ask questions
about this shit isn't be like, oh my God,
what are you a fucking Trump supporter?
I'm really excited to go to this wedding.
He's saying, okay, these two gay guys are
getting married, great to gay fellows.
As he says, I'm really excited to go minus
the fact that they are dancing fools.
Could they be more stereotypical?
Uh,
my girl and that whole group will be
dancing the night away. Well. So wedding.
Yeah.
Okay.
Do you not want to do this? No,
I'm just trying to, I'm, I'm,
I should wait to hear the question
fully. Please proceed. Okay.
You seem annoyed if any point you need
to walk out and I'm fine with it. Okay.
He says me for me. He says
me for me or me, I just feel,
he says me. I'm not a dancer.
Perhaps I shouldn't assume,
but I'm assuming that
you're no dancer yourself.
Evidently he is not seen
daddy's home rights. Um,
I'm the worst. I'm your standard pasty
white guy who doesn't really dance.
I don't like it. I don't really understand
it. It's just, it don't understand.
Just seems goofy to me.
I totally lined up with this guy.
I have an appreciation for it.
You're on the bay.
You danced at the wedding though. You
dance at our wedding all night long. Yeah,
I was drunk.
My girlfriend has her dislike
with my opinion of dancing after a couple
of drinks going as far as to tell me
it's a real disappointment.
[inaudible] that I don't enjoy
dancing. Oh, I love how honest she is.
You know, it's a real disappointment,
uh, in our four years together. Have you,
but I'm really,
this really went in and I completely
don't respect the fact that you don't like
something that I like. Hey
Nia, do you like hockey?
Uh, I'll do what I do. Could
you just play along? No,
I doubt that's a real disappointment.
Um, um, in our four years together,
we've never really had any
sort of arguments other
than that one. Jesus Christ.
That's the only thing you are,
you about how you're very lucky.
How often do you guys go marry this girl?
He goes,
I don't try and guilt her into
doing something she doesn't like.
So I get a little hot blooded
when she does it to me. Hi.
Can she see you'll be dancing to that one?
How blood?
It wasn't a god robber.
Hundred and three.
Come on, baby. Do more. They dance
right here. That's another white guy.
Doesn't want to dance. They do more to
dance. Can we get outta here so we get a,
yeah, invent herpes. Uh, well, what
do you think? What do you think? Oh,
Ruby Pubi Ruby Pews Day.
Um,
I don't stand my ground in what do
I stand my ground and what will most
definitely become a disagreement
when I don't go flail around.
Like the non dancing whitey that I am
or do I sack up and do my best Travolta
from pulp fiction and go attempt to cut
some rug even though I'll be miserable
the whole time. Best to you? Uh,
your little one and season two of
f is for family has been great.
Thanks for the content. And go f yourself.
All right. All right. All right. So, um,
what do you say? Well, as I'm
snarkily said earlier, it's a wedding.
So obviously there's going to be dancing
whether they're gay guys are straight.
Like everybody dances at weddings.
Let's not,
I don't know how he explains like why
would he think that there wouldn't be
dancing? Maybe that's not the, had
nothing to do with the gay guy.
He was just saying he doesn't want to,
he just doesn't want to dance.
No one can dance.
Oh, let little thing about
me is a way that I wo
I don't know. Oh listen,
girls that liked to dance,
like guys that liked to dance with them.
That's just how it is that the
name of a new reality show.
If you don't go in there and do
the why MCA and the electric slide,
you can at least do a couple of slow
dances. How about that? Can you come? Hi.
Made me outside.
How [inaudible] knows cashmere that um,
maybe that can be the compromise. Listen,
I'm not going to go up there. YMCAS
break. Good out dude. Dude, dude,
this is not the karaoke singing.
So none of those things
were [inaudible] prince.
Did we have prints at our wedding? I don't
know. Let's let's stay focused on, yes.
I think the compromise,
sir,
is that you should give your lady a
couple of slow dances and also also,
wait a minute.
It's one night.
It's not going to kill you to get
up there and like be goofy with her.
No one's watching you because I feel
like there's a little bit of you that's
like, you don't like to dance cause
you feel like you can't dance.
Nobody's looking at you, nobody's judging
you. It's one night out of your life.
Just be silly, have fun with it
and definitely slow dance with her.
She'll really appreciate it.
This was one of those times where even
though you don't like doing something,
you do it for the person that you love.
This is what it isn't. My suggestion.
You're not going out dancing
every single Saturday.
Would you both for the wedding?
You should.
I'm a little distracted so I'm sorry
I can't put my mouth like, you know,
you want me to blow the damn
microphone? No, I just want you to,
he can do. He just, hello?
I feel I can't drive a car.
Don't do that.
I just,
this is what he should do.
He should go go there and
have five quick drinks,
five,
five get fucking hammered and then
just go out there and then just,
that's it.
You blackout drunk.
I don't think that's a good walk around
like a fish out of water the next day.
I don't agree.
When you're hung over and you're
laying there and she's giving you look,
she just looked at her and your best Clint
Eastwood voice and you just feel like
it was your idea.
You want me to dance?
These are the rules that would
just sell. It said, listen,
I'm going to dance my ass off that night.
Okay,
and I want you to know how stupid I'm
going to feel. I'm doing this for you.
However, these are the rules. You
line up five shots. I'm doing those
like Mister Blonde
going through that bank.
That bad, bad, bad, bad, bad.
If you had made me go out
on the fucking dance floor,
I don't think he should get a good
mister blonde. That was all right.
I don't think he should be five shots
wasted. Break. Thank [inaudible].
Would you accept three? I would
take two and see how it goes. Oh,
you're the worst three. Give him
three. This gives us a major anxiety.
Need to think of all this stuff you
all like to do, right? Exactly. Yeah,
but I'm just saying at,
well how about this?
Can he at least give her us
salad before he gets wasted?
Can you just give her a slow,
cause we love slow dances.
They don't start with the slow dance.
I know you go out there and it's like
immediately like medially. Get down on it.
Yeah, get down on it.
Don't Du du, Du du Du du
Du du Doo Doo Doo Doo
to the pain.
Was it?
I'm just barely doing the neutron dates.
The team and someone stole
my brand new Chevrolet.
Yeah. At that point you've got to be like,
you gotta be like fucking, you gotta be,
you gotta be five shots in.
It's one night out of your life.
Do it cause you love her.
Chosed and say,
this is my dancing for the
year given love you Mo.
He's gotta be Shit faced. Can you
just let the guy get drunk? Nia,
I don't say this a lot. I don't see
this lot. This is a white thing.
What do you mean we don't do, we don't
dance. Why people dance all the time.
Fred Astaire. We did do it
professionally. We just don't do it.
Read reason. One of those
people on dancing with the
stars and that's it. I know.
All right. Here's another one for a
girl at Jujitsu. Hey, Billy Biloxi.
So my dilemma
is I'm 18 and I've checked on my,
it's hot is frigging Health Indiana.
You turn the AC on because what am I
supposed to, oh, I'll hit pause. Hang on.
All right, I'm back. Here we go.
So my dilemma is I'm 18 and
I've just finished the first,
my first year of college a few months
ago and I've been hitting the gym.
Good for you as much as possible. Good
for you. And I've been going to Jujitsu.
You're crushing it for the past couple
of months. Anyway, first day going there,
I noticed a girl in the beginner's class
with me and thought she was hot and
she's doing Jujitsu.
This is,
this is nothing but a great stuff so
far. Uh, so after a couple of weeks,
I work up the nerve to talk to work.
Good for you.
Turns out I went to school with the
younger brothers, something in common.
This is like all rainbows right now.
And I was also the youngest in my year,
so I think she might be 19 or 20.
Jesus Christ,
this is just all aces. Uh Oh. Why does
my computer screen keeps shutting down?
Um, I don't know. Anyway, after
train, I don't know. Anyway,
after training yesterday I asked her,
I asked for her snapchat.
Is that the way millennials as for
digits now. I never even said digits.
I'd be like, what's your
number? Can I call you?
You like my z Kaveri cheese.
Daisy Buchanan instilled itself Micmac it.
Try not to curse in front of her even
though I've already done it 50 times here.
I don't know any, I don't know.
Anyway, it's a triple blah blah.
And she gave it to me and
after I asked her for it,
I felt like a weight had been lifted
because I've never really talked to that
many girls, let alone get their
snapchat or whatever is good for you.
Cause I'm incredibly reluctant and
a bit scared to talk to them. Yeah,
pathetic. I know, but I think this
girl, his girlfriend material,
that's not pathetic.
Not just a fuck one time bitch.
That was pathetic. Yeah. He really
just made a left turn there.
That statement was pathetic. He kind of
built himself up as the AW shucks guy.
Yeah. And then he now turn it around
into, now he's a lady killer. Yeah.
Well I know what it is.
What he's afraid of.
Low of whatever. No, no g see what you
just did you just turn her off. Alright,
I think I'm solo on this one. Um,
so Billy boy, what should I do?
How should I go about this?
How should I text her?
Any advice would be a pro appreciated.
Loved the podcast.
Wouldn't mind hearing for the lovely
knee as input to have possible.
We'd love for you. Can you just
let a guy be a guy woods near?
That's the equivalent. You guys being
like, well what does he do for a living?
How much does he make the, Oh,
what size house could I get when I,
oh, is that the equivalent bill? Yes.
Equivalents equivalent as equal. Nobody's
onsite that at least not on my son.
Oh, sorry. And I, God, for me,
I feel I need a twin from house.
However your friends talk,
we'd love for you to like play
a Gig in Ireland sometime.
Thanks to go f yourself too. I played
a Gig, I played three last year.
I went from Dublin up to Belfast and out
to Galway and an Isosceles triangle of
freckled. Fuckos I perform two
out there. Are you trying to be
bad ass with this whole,
not a one time bitch fuck type of thing.
Like what was that? What was that
little statement he threw in there?
Because that did really turn me off.
Why do you keep latching onto that?
This guy has all kinds of great qualities.
He's 18 he's, he's, he's
one year into college. Okay.
He's hitting the gym, he's taking
Jujitsu. He saw a beautiful woman.
He was smitten by her and he's nervous.
Okay.
He loosely used it's locker room talk to,
they just don't understand why he has,
I just don't build a wall
around categorizing girls
that he doesn't even know.
And so this is like the kind of bitches
fuck ones and this is girlfriend
material. Go fuckers. So
how about your neither,
how about you're not going to get laid?
And you're an asshole that won't have
a girlfriend. And how about that?
How does that feel,
Mimi? How Sad. How about
dad? It's gets me out. Yeah,
you guys do the same thing.
We're not talking about what you
guys do and what everybody else does.
I'm talking about this person that wrote
in this question. Okay, that's not,
that's not what this conversation is
about. What everybody knows child,
I want her to feel my
passion. Okay. No. Oh her,
her. Um, I'm not, we are,
we're not discussing what
women do versus what men do.
We're talking about this particular
person who is like, oh good for you.
You got her snapchat also like snapshot,
grow a pair and get her number. If you're
really trying to like come with it,
like don't be lurking on her snapchat
so you can like jerk off to her like
little selfie pics. I'm annoyed with this
person. I'm sorry. I just, you know what?
I'm jealous of this person.
You know what son?
I don't want to eat and he's working
out, you know, the general appreciation,
that little line that you threw in,
so married his wife,
that type of way about
it. So, um, all right,
here's my advice, sir. Here's my advice.
You know something, I swear to God,
if you were a pitcher right now I'm
coming out and before you even get to the
mountain of taking you out of the game,
I don't even know what that means.
It means you got way too emotional.
You lost your control and you're gonna,
you're gonna kill somebody,
hit the shower.
She's girlfriend material, not
just a one time the, you know,
bitch you fuck was this guy cannot
run in from the bullpen quick enough.
You've completely lost your composure.
Hit the showers on this one. All right.
How do you know what kind
of person she is? Oh boy.
Cause you decided because
you've projected what?
You want your fantasy because she's
out a real person to you, right?
She's not a real person. She's just
someone you saw doing Jujitsu and is like,
oh my God,
this is like my dream girl.
Not like those other girls that
you just like tossed to the side.
You don't even know her. You don't even
care to know her. You got her snapchat,
her snapchat really via.
Oh,
a pair asked for the number
or stay the fuck away.
Don't be lurking online like some kind of
creep. What does this person saying? Oh,
he's from Ireland.
Colin.
Mia,
don't Seamus.
Shame is only airy. Uh, no
shame is this guy has no Seamus,
I'm sorry. Sorry.
Patrick. Listen. Yes. Um,
don't you hit [inaudible] guys have
like, oh, this guy's husband material.
Yes. Well, all right then. So
why don't you relax. All right,
good luck, Lord. I do get it. I
really got hot. You got grumpy.
All right, fine. Yes, this is it. There
are days that you're like this guy,
you would not want to be in relationship.
This is a guy that you just like bang
out a few times and don't ever see again.
Yes. That, what do you mean
bang out a few times? No,
you're right. You're right. Women do
the same thing. It's, it's 100% true. I,
it just took 20 minutes to get there. I
Dunno. Just bug me, of course bugged me.
But I am being a hypocrite because I've
certainly had those feelings towards
certain guys, so, exactly.
And it's about time I start fucking
admitting then instead of acting like the
world ozo rounded drinks.
Now here's a man he's found,
he's smitten with this
girl. He's afraid, you know?
So he just in the tooth
coming in their house. Yes.
Well, this is what I would say. Uh,
how should you go about this? Uh,
you're gonna have to do something that's
probably difficult at your age.
And I hate when older people say this,
but you got to figure out a way to
be yourself. You just gotta walk. I,
you've said enough there and I
think you've said, I'm sorry Shane.
I'm sorry I yelled at you.
I think you've said enough here.
I think you dumped a whole bunch
of other stuff from other days.
Was it something I did? I don't know.
But this guy did not deserve that.
This is an 18 year old. He
just became a man. Okay. Okay.
I overreacted a little bit and
he's a colleague don't to college.
He's going to know how to defend his
family bag full of goodies. Right?
With his Jujitsu. I'm just saying, if you
were my son, I'd be like, can you not?
Can you get off at Nia? Alright, a
Moffett on. Yeah, you're a hypocrite.
You're a hypocrite.
But what I love about you is you admit
what a pig you are like the rest of us.
Jesus Christ.
Can you give the kid some advice here?
What was the question?
He got her snapchat and he's nervous.
He actually likes this woman.
What does he do?
Is you just be himself just to listen.
I got to like I,
I saw you across the room.
A man one was a little mini heart attacks.
I really like you. I'd like to
take you out. You've got it.
You got to go on a stage is asking.
Yeah,
you don't have to sit there and brewed
in the corner and there no reason to feed
. What you do is you, you,
you fake with those ones.
You just going to bang somebody actually
like you gotta be honest with them or
else it's not gonna work.
So just a, yeah. Okay.
This level one is getting filled up.
I see. I'm going to go. Okay, cool.
I think you will get, I think you
both need a nap. Yeah, I know.
I'm sorry about that. Hey, we all
get there. Whatever his name is. It's
my bad. Yeah. Well all you
know his name is Vinny. Um,
all right.
Okay.
Dancing at the wedding. I already
did that girl, that Jiu Jitsu.
I already did that. Did I answer all
the questions? Oh, joining the army,
joining the army as you can
sail the seven seas in the army.
You can eat some mushy peas in the arm.
You'll get joining the army. Dear William,
no fun.
I'll skip all the ass kissing since you
blow through all your bolts through on
your reads. Anyways. All right.
I'm a 34 year old married guy,
former navy vet [inaudible] who
is sick of feeling like a shitbag.
I want to do something with my life
and feel like making a difference.
I've kicked around the idea of going back
into the military for a while now and
it's shit or get off the pot time.
MMM.
Why you want to go back into the military?
34 okay.
I brought this up to my wife in the past
in all she can say is you're married
and changes the subject,
so backstory on us,
we've been together for seven
years and married fiveish.
We've had our ups and
downs like any couple,
but I get sick of being treated like
a child. It comes to my own life
anyway.
I'm just about at the cutoff age cutoff,
age wise to go down the
path I want in life.
I want to be a combat
medic. Jesus Christ. Dude,
good lord man. I mean how much
excitement that you need in your life.
You already serve and you want to go
back here and this guy's a frigging hero
here.
He said,
I'm a determined man who cares about
my family and my family and my country.
I've done my research and I have the
time to join. Do the medic training,
Goto Rasp,
ranger assessment program.
You're going to become
an army ranger at 34.
Did you guys ever watched that
documentary on Netflix about
just to see if you're worthy of,
of going through like the week
long of 10 days or 14 days of hell?
Only thing I remember was they had
this giant like telephone pole that you
intend of. The guys had to hold up
and do curls with it or some shit
and his people quit.
The rest of you had to hold the thing up.
I mean I was screaming in pain watching it
and if you puked in the pit you had
to get your puke out of the pit.
It was just like,
just that beginning thing
was more obstacles than
I've ever faced in my entire
life. Um, you are a driven man.
You're a special kind of person, man.
If you can, does special forces, right?
He says then special operations, combat
medic training. My question is built,
what do I do here? Do I risk losing
her or stay here and resent her?
I don't want to do either,
but I also can't continue to work myself
to death as a construction worker.
Making someone else rich at the cost
of my health and happiness. Dude,
if you want to be a combat medic
in your fucking putting drywall in,
I mean that's gotta be torturing you.
He said,
I've worked seven twelves for six
months, six, seven days a week,
12 hours a day for six goddamn months
trying to save money to go to nursing
school.
She tells me she booked us on a cruise.
She spent that money on a cruise,
Lee.
Oh boy. I don't know what
to do and I need your help.
Thanks in advance for your advice
and thanks for the [inaudible].
Mediocre job on F is for
family. Go Fuck Yourself. All
right, here's the deal, dude.
Um, what's going on in your
relationship and is a, is,
is a critical lack of communication.
Okay?
You're telling her what you want to do.
She's just saying you're married,
changes to subject your, you've saved up
all that money to go to nursing school.
And either she didn't realize that that
was what it was for and booked you on a
cruise or
she's one of the most
selfish people on the planet,
which I don't think you
would've brought that up.
So I think what's going on
here is you're one of these,
you're disguise guy, John Wayne
type. And like most of them,
you know, people like that. You ask you
how you're doing and you just say, fine.
All right, well you need to do what?
You got to open up. You got to sit down.
You got to say,
listen,
we got to talk and you have to sit down
and didn't tell her what you want to do.
Tell her how you feel at work and you
have to communicate and start there and
work your way
to the ranger assessment program.
That's what you have to do.
MMM.
Because other than that,
uh, you have a major blowout
argument on the horizon and
her catchphrase is going to be,
where is all of this coming from?
Okay.
You know?
MMM,
Yup. If you're one of those guys that does
stuff the right way, there's a problem.
You can run into where you
have this expectation that
everybody else should also
do things the right way. And when they
don't, then you get fucking pissed.
And uh, it's, it's all of
it builds it as complete.
Like I lead by example and all that shit.
You got to learn how to communicate.
So yeah, I would sit down with her and I
would talk to her. Um, all right. And, uh,
good luck with that.
Those are amazing frigging goals.
I just want to learn how to play Tommy
the cat. That's what I want to do
anyways. That's the podcast,
everybody. I hope you enjoyed it. Um,
by the way, I have, um,
I have a number of friends on that show.
A,
I'm dying up here and uh,
they're telling me that
as good as the pilot was,
it just keeps getting better
and better and better.
And there's a zillion shows out there,
so they really need people to watch. Um,
the book was fucking incredible.
I know Jim Carey's names attached to it,
so I know it's going to be great. I'm
going to watch episode two right now. Uh,
Al Madrigal the great
Al Madrigal, um, who I,
uh, you know, do the all things
comedy podcast network with,
and it's just a friend in
general is killing it on there.
MMM.
I don't know. I hope you guys watch
the show cause I'm, I'm really, uh,
I really, I'm really enjoying it. I'm
enjoying a family van keys. All right.
So what am I going to do here? Is there
anything else I need to fucking say?
Anything else that I need to hype here?
Um,
should I give a shout out to anything?
I already gave you a shout out to flee
for saving the bees.
I wonder if enough people,
fuck it did that,
you know,
I still can't believe that
I pulled photosynthesis and
of my age and in a way I
came up with that one. Um, all right,
that's it. Everybody check out.
I'm dying up here and, uh,
I'll check it on Ya on, on, uh,
what is it Thursday?
Is that what it is?
Is that what it is? Oh, Andrew Santina
was on it. Here we go. Eric Griffin.
I'm going to get everybody.
John Daly fucking hilarious.
Um, oh, well, so who else?
Scroll and Rick Overton.
Rick Overton met him back in the day.
Speaking of neutron dance was
actually in Beverly Hills Cop. Don,
my rare is fucking hilarious on it.
I'm gonna Watch that right now.
That's what I'm doing after I upload
this podcast. All right, everybody,
I hope every, all the dads out there
had a wonderful father's day. Uh,
it was an incredible day for me to
finally get texts and tweets from people
wished me happy father's Day. It meant a
lot to me. Thank you so much. That is it.
I will, uh, check in or night
check ain't on you. There you go.
That's how you say it on
Thursday. All right. Bye Bye.